der präsident ich möchte ihnen zunächst
einmal meine
romane befindet sich
es ist bewundernswert wie die
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer sich gegen
die invasion russlands zur wehr setzen
dafür lieber herr präsident soll ich ihn
soll deutschland in großen respekt
gemeinsam mit seinem französischen
amtskollegen dem italienischen
ministerpräsidenten und dem rumänischen
präsidenten bin ich heute gastiert
gekommen um ihnen das auch ganz
persönlich außen zu drücken
klar ist dieser überfall auf die ukraine
markiert eine zeitenwende
in russland versucht mit gewalt grenzen
innerhalb europas zu verschieben
das ist unakzeptabel und
deshalb hat sich deutschland gemeinsam
mit vielen anderen länder in der welt
vom ersten tag an eng an die seite der
ukraine gestellt
wir unterstützen die ukraine dabei ihre
souveränität und territoriale integrität
zu verteidigen finanziell mit hohen
zuwendungen wie gegeben humanitäre indem
wir mehr als 800.000 geflüchtete in
deutschland aufgenommen haben um in
schutz und obdach zu bieten
135.000 kinder gehen inzwischen auf
deutsche schulen
in deutschland mit einer langen starts
tradition gebrochen wir unterstützen die
ukraine auch mit der lieferung von
waffen- und wir werden das weiterhin tun
solange die ukraine unsere stützung
bemüht
gerade irgendwie ukrainisches militär
modernsten waffen aus an der
panzerhaubitze 2000 am flugabwehr panzer
gebhart
zusätzlich habe ich zugesagt dass
moderne flugabwehrsysteme ihr system zu
liefern dass eine ganze großstadt gegen
luftangriffe verteidigen kann und das
spezial randa cobra
und wir haben nun gemeinsam mit den
vereinigten staaten von amerika und
großbritannien an den trilateralen
vereinbarung getroffen und werden der
ukraine mehrfach raketenwerfer geben sie
sehen deutschland unterstützt die
ukraine massiv
meine damen und herren mal den kollegen
und ich sind heute hier nach kiew
gekommen mit einer klaren botschaft
die ukraine gehört zur europäischen
familie
ein meilenstein auf ihrem voraussetzung
reichen europäischen weg ist der status
eines beitrittskandidaten
darüber beraten die mitgliedstaaten der
europäischen union in den nächsten tagen
wir wissen dass braucht einstimmigkeit
unter den 27 eu-ländern
beim europäischen rat werde ich mich für
eine einheitliche haltung staat machen
deutschland ist für eine positive
entscheidung zugunsten der ukraine
das gilt auch für die republik moldau
und es ist eine frage der europäischen
glaubwürdigkeit dass wir gegenüber den
staaten des westlichen balkan die sich
seit jahren schon auf diesem weg
befinden nun endlich unsere versprechen
einlösen jetzt und konkret
für den weiteren europäischen union
gelten klare kriterien die von allen
kandidaten erfüllt werden müssen das
gilt für die gemeinsam in der eu
vereinbarten regeln inaki insbesondere
mit blick auf demokratie und
rechtsstaatlichkeit
demokratie und rechtsstaatlichkeit sind
das was uns in der europäischen union
zusammen führt und von anderen
unterscheidet
abschließend möchte ich noch etwas
offensichtliches ansprechen die eu muss
sich auf diese entwicklung vorbereiten
und ihre strukturen und verfahren
modernisieren
meine damen und herren
die ukraine soll eben
slava ihn
scholze und seine europäischen kollegen
conradi und johannes haben in kiew
verkündet dass die ukraine ein
sofortiger eu beitrittskandidat werden
soll ein historischer tag sagte italiens
ministerpräsident draghi an dem zweimal
die sirenen heulten luftalarm während
die staats und regierungschefs in kiel
erfahren und all das hat unser reporter
vor ort paul ronzheimer
beobachtet mit dem wir jetzt verbunden
sind hoffe ich da ist er auch paul lasst
uns diese
pressekonferenz die wir gerade gehört
haben und auch diesen tag ein bisschen
einordnen ein historischer tag sagt
draghi würdest du das auch so sehen
historisch in dem sinne dass die
eu-beitrittsperspektive angeht das
stimmt natürlich das ist richtig das ist
aber schon so ein bisschen das was man
erwartet hat in der ukraine also wir
stellen uns mal vor schuld trage ich mal
kreuzen das verweigert das hätte hier
für maximalen aufschrei gesorgt aus
meiner sicht wäre das gar nicht möglich
gewesen auch in der öffentlichen meinung
ihnen das jetzt zu verwehren das muss
man immer wieder erklären thomas da geht
es ja tatsächlich erst einmal um eine
perspektive und das heißt noch gar nicht
das heißt nicht dass man eu mitglied
wird sondern nur dass die chance
eröffnet ist von daher historisch glaube
ich ist etwas anderes vielleicht ist es
historisch allein die tatsache dass drei
oder vier staatschefs in dem moment dort
zusammen standen das war für mich das
eigentliche zeichen das symbol auch an
russ und man hat ja an den reaktionen
von premierminister mit word abgesehen
der dann mit leberwurst vergleichen kam
und pasta und die sind da hingefahren
diese staatschefs das bringt sowieso
nichts und die russische propaganda die
dann vom angriff auf deutschland phase
also da hat man gesehen dass hat
russland wirklich getroffen und das
dritte thema glaube ich das wird in der
ukraine weiter diskutiert werden
frankreich hat so ein bisschen waffen
angekündigt vier weitere haubitzen waren
es dass die mancunians liefern will das
ist nicht das was die ukraine sich
vorstellt da war ja von hunderten und
tausenden die rede die man brauche also
aus dem ganzen westen nicht von
einzelnen ländern allein und was
deutschland angeht oder scholz hat sich
zu neuen waffen nicht geäußert sondern
ist sehr theoretisch geblieben hat
gesagt dass man weiter alles tut um die
ukraine zu unterstützen auch militärisch
ist dann nicht ins detail gegangen sie
den ski hat sich bedankt für die
unterstützung und dann bemerkenswert
emotional für olaf scholz wie er sein
presse statement mit slava ukraine
abschluss ja ganz genau in der tat und
er hat darauf hingewiesen dass
deutschland ja auch acht hunderttausende
flüchtlinge aufgenommen habe aus der
ukraine
135.000 kinder aus der ukraine würden
jetzt auf deutsche schulen gehen dass
auch noch mal eine kleine replik
natürlich auch auf die kritik von
botschafter melnik hier die ukrainische
flüchtlinge würden sich in deutschland
nicht wohl fühlen sie lenski hat auch
noch mal ausdrücklich betont ich glaube
dass das deutsche volk die das ganze
deutsche volk die ukraine unterstützt da
bin ich mir sicher
genau so ist ist er ist noch mal auf
diese punkte eingegangen die ihr auch
wichtig sind denn die gene mal ein
bisschen unter in dieser waffen
diskussion dass natürlich deutschland da
sehr viel tut aber er ist nicht aufgrund
des drucks thomas das muss man ganz klar
sagen er hat keine neue rhetorik dort
gefunden also wenn man noch mal zurück
schaut auf den heutigen tag ich habe den
kanzler ja sehr nahe begleitet dort den
alpinen in dem vorort diese heftig
betroffen war von den russischen
einkesselung von den angriffen die
zerstörten häuser und dort habe ich
einen kanzler gesehen der wirklich
mitgenommen war sichtlich gezeichnet er
saß danach noch in seinem auto bis die
kolonne losfuhr und man hat in seinen
augen gesehen das sind das wahnsinnig
beschäftigt hat nun ist er früher als
kanzler früher als vizekanzler
finanzminister und bürgermeister nicht
so häufig in krisenregionen gefahren
glaube ich also für ihn auch eine
besondere erfahrung immer noch hier im
kriegszustand auch kia freak raketen vor
einer woche erst wieder ein gewinn in
die stadt die stadt bombardiert worden
und auch heute gab es zweimal
sirenenalarm das noch relativ ruhig
geblieben aber dieses ereignis dort in
alpinen das hat man gesehen dass hat
sich beim kanzler eingebrannt wir
schauen uns diese bilder mal an vom
kanzler in ihre paul und sprechen gleich
weiter
olaf scholz in den ruinen von der
bundeskanzler ist in der ukraine
angekommen direkt in der realität des
krieges
umso schlimmer wenn man sieht wie
furchtbar sinnlos diese gewalt die wir
sehen sind
unschuldige zivilisten betroffen sind
häuser zerstört worden ist eine ganze
stadt zerstört worden der überhaupt
keine militärischen infrastrukturen
waren und das sagt sehr viel aus über
die qualität des holzschneiders schickt
er einfach auf zerstörung und eroberung
aus es ist der tag des olaf scholz der
tag auf denen die ukraine und auch
europa warten der tag an dem der
bundeskanzler ein zeichen setzen soll in
der dunkelheit geht es los mit dem
nachtzug an bord die drei wichtigsten
staats und regierungschefs europas
bundeskanzler olaf scholz reist mit
frankreichs präsident emanuel makro und
italiens ministerpräsident mario draghi
im sonderzug nach 4 bis 2 uhr 17
diskutieren die staatsmänner in macros
abteil um 8 uhr 29 deutscher zeit
erreicht der nachtzug den zentralbahnhof
von kia für die drei staatsmänner ist es
der erste besuch in der ukraine seit
kriegsbeginn die mission
es ist eine botschaft des europäischen
zusammenhalt für die menschen in der
ukraine eine botschaft der unterstützung
jetzt und in zukunft
denn die nächsten wochen werden
schwierig werden nur wenig später die
ankunft der staatschefs im hotel der
besuch von scholz makro und draghi
findet statt einen tag bevor die eu
kommission eine empfehlung über den eu
beitritt der ukraine ab und wichtigster
termin jetzt das treffen mit wladimir
selensky der präsident der ukraine hofft
auf deutliche zusagen von
waffenlieferungen und die unterstützung
seines landes
schon im vorfeld sich hatte kanzler
scholz zu der besuch werde kein reiner
fototermin werden doch was genau er
versprechen wird ist streng geheim
plötzlich dröhnt sirenenalarm in der
ukrainischen hauptstadt große attacken
mitten in den so wichtigen und lange
geplanten besuch in diesem moment
sirenenalarm in kiew während der
bundeskanzler hier in der stadt ist der
bundeskanzler mitten im raum
kriegsalltag der ukraine betroffenheit
auf den gesichtern von scholz makro und
draghi beim besuch von lpr team gehört
neben butter zu den vororten der
ukrainischen hauptstadt kiew in denen
russische soldaten kriegsverbrechen an
der zivilbevölkerung begangen haben die
menschen der ukraine hoffen auf ein
starkes signal der staatsmänner eine
deutliche reaktion westeuropas auf 113
tage krieg
jorgos tosic
ist wieder auf sendung
das starke signal so endete der beitrag
gerade darauf hofften die ukraine wir
haben vorhin angesprochen da es ja
einzige wirkliche signal muss man sagen
die ukraine soll jetzt ein sofortiger eu
beitrittskandidat werden im grunde ist
das eigentlich nur sagen wir mal eine
abkürzung von ungefähr einem jahr da
muss man normalerweise einen langen
fragenkatalog
beantworten als land als ukraine das
geht jetzt dann ganz fix aber die
eigentlichen verhandlungen also dieser
lange lange weg in die eu wer kann viele
viele viele jahre dauern auch jahrzehnte
dauern da müssen halt viele bedingungen
auch erfüllt werden vielleicht können
wir darüber kurz sprechen paule zum
einen muss es eine funktionierende
wirtschaft geben eine stabile demokratie
eine unabhängige justiz aber auch vor
allem bekämpfung der korruption
beispielsweise im land und da sehen
selbst die ukraine laut transparency
international eines der größten probleme
absolut das ist ein weiter weg ein
steiniger weg und wenn man sich die
anderen beitrittskandidaten anschaut in
bestimmten themen zumindest schon weiter
waren dann auch schwierig und nicht klar
ob es am ende zu einer mitgliedschaft
kommt aber thomas auch da geht es glaube
ich jetzt in diesem moment auch in den
schweren tagen des krieges mit dieser
geschichte dieses landes man dafür nie
vergessen wie 2014 auf dem majdan denn
im monat einmal unabhängigkeitsplatz die
menschen mit europäischen flaggen
demonstriert haben damals gegen diktator
janukowitsch gegen die korruption im
land also es gibt diese jungen
entschlossenen die das land verändern
wollen die frage ist ob sie sich
durchsetzen werden können und vor allem
was der krieg mit diesem land macht aber
dass die mehrheit im land eine
europäische perspektive will dass man
sich europäisch fühlt das merke ich hier
als reporter im land immer wieder das
herz schlägt europäisch ja die ukraine
gehört zur europäischen familie das arme
makro ja auch betonte olaf scholz hat es
auch gesagt wir haben
auch gerade am anfang als der krieg
ausbrach und auch die angriffe auf
kirchen oft darüber gesprochen dass dies
eine wirkliche europäische
innenstadt ja auch ist gerade bei jungen
leuten die dort
hinreisen also das
eigentlich eine selbstverständlichkeit
inzwischen dass die ukraine zu europa
gehört die frage ist was wird das
konkret bedeuten
ich glaube darüber macht sich in der
ukraine momentan die menschen nicht so
ganz viele gedanken denn es geht jetzt
erstmal darum dass das land bestehen
kann thomas wir leben im osten die
angriffe jeden tag sterben 100 soldaten
wir erleben dass dörfer überrannt werden
städte und das liegt daran dass man eben
nicht genügend waffen dort hat deswegen
glaube ich dass muss man auch sagen bei
aller euphorie vielleicht einzelner
politiker über dieses thema also über
die frage der eu-mitgliedschaft die drei
wussten schon warum sie sich dieses
thema aufgehoben haben ja das ist auch
die woche aber natürlich lenkt ist auch
ab von den anderen problemen die es hier
gibt oder von den viel größeren fragen
und größeren existenziellen fragen denn
eins ist doch klar thomas wenn russland
hier die ukraine zerstört wenn russland
schafft noch mal hier nach kiew zu
kommen und es dann vielleicht
einzunehmen dann brauchen wir nicht über
eine eu perspektive sprechen dann ist
dieses land kaputt deswegen es gibt
gerade um die existenz der ukraine und
deswegen freuen sich die ukraine
sicherlich einerseits dass diese
perspektive da ist aber man will erst
einmal da muss erst mal das eigene land
retten und das ist glaube ich gerade das
entscheiden folgen natürlich auch für
europa zum einen finanzielle folgen auch
als
beitrittskandidat hat ein land dann
anrecht auf unterstützung und natürlich
ein rattenschwanz der da dran hängt denn
auch die
westbalkanstaaten die lange schon
beitrittskandidaten sein wollen darauf
warten dass dieser prozess beginnt auch
den muss natürlich zugesagt werden okay
das gilt dann für euch jetzt auch die
republik moldau soll ebenfalls kandidat
werden auch georgien starke signale
natürlich auch richtung russland vor
allem da rückt europa dann zumindest
schon mal symbolisch russland immer
näher
nein das sehe ich nicht so denn wenn wir
uns anschauen wie über die ukraine
diskutiert worden ist auch in den
vergangenen monaten waren immer klar
oder vergangenen jahren dass man diese
europäische perspektive sucht und was
russland oder wladimir putin jetzt noch
als vermeintlichen provokation sieht
oder bezeichnet oder sich zusammen
labert ich glaube nicht dass die eu da
irgendeine rücksicht darauf nehmen
sollte dennoch einmal wert diesen krieg
begonnen das war russland ohne dass es
irgendeine art von provokation der
ukrainischen seite gab das heißt die
ukraine sollte überrollt werden und wird
noch weiter überrollt was die
finanziellen hilfen angeht da muss man
ja ernst ehrlich sagen dass diese längst
fließen und zwar seit vielen monaten und
vielen jahren was die hilfe angeht und
insbesondere seit dem krieg und nicht
nur aus europa sondern auch von den usa
von joe biden der gestern zb ein
erneutes milliarden paket angekündigt
hat für waffenlieferungen
ich glaube nicht dass diese diskussion
um die eu perspektive der ukraine jetzt
so groß wird ja das geht jetzt noch mal
diese woche am ende der woche aber
momentan ist es doch alles sehr
symbolisch noch einmal dieses land ist
im krieg sehr symbolisch auch das foto
das er mir gerade nochmal eingeblendet
haben während du gesprochen dass paul
wir stehen also diese vier europäischen
staats- und regierungschefs
da im anzug und mittendrin selensky in
seiner gewohnten militär kluft dort auch
wenn es wirklich völlig egal ist aber in
den sozialen medien macht auch sagen die
kleidungswahl von olaf scholz daher
heute morgen dort in jeans mit einem
schwarzen kurzärmligen hemd angereist
ist macht der große furore wird so was
dort in der ukraine in irgendeiner form
wahrgenommen
auch nur in den sozialen medien
ansonsten spielt die kleidungswahl keine
rolle ich gehe davon aus dass die
staatschefs abgestimmt haben vorher auch
dass sie dann alle krawatte getragen
haben nun ich gebe dir recht ist war
schon ein ungewöhnliches bild
tatsächlich die meisten regierungschefs
und minister die zu besuch waren haben
nicht zumindest keinen schlips getragen
einer der früher schon hier war boris
johnson der ist auch mit schlips mit
seinen stil durch die stadt gelaufen
also nicht völlig etwas ungewöhnliches
und selen ski bleibt seinem outfit treue
ich nehme an er bleibt diesem auftritt
auch so lange treu wie der krieg dauert
das tat trägt er seit kriegsbeginn
dieses t shirt das ist zum jahr fast
einem komischen t shirt geworden dass
auf allen fotos zu sehen ist und wir
wissen wo die residenz gearbeitet sehr
viel mit bildern mit symbolen deswegen
bleibt er im krieg so lange der krieg
läuft zumindest jetzt so wie er ist
die frage ist was ertragen würde wenn er
tatsächlich zum g 7 gipfel nach ellmau
kommen würde er hat ja die einladung
zumindest angenommen von olaf scholz an
dem gipfel teilzunehmen bisher hat er
das alles natürlich virtuell gemachte
aus kiew heraus und es ist dann auch
nicht glaube ich mittlerweile oder gibt
es schon informationen inzwischen ob er
das wieder virtuell machen wird oder ob
er womöglich tatsächlich dorthin reisen
würde
das ist noch nicht ganz klar ob er das
virtuell machen wird oder dorthin reiste
ich nehme an das hängt auch sehr stark
damit zusammen wie die front situation
ist denn man stelle sich vor russland
würde in den tagen des g7 einen großen
durchbruch oder eine große offensive
erfolgreich durchführen oder präsident
ist nicht im land dass es nicht so
leicht das heißt da muss er genau
entscheiden ob er wirklich raus kann was
das bedeutet ich denke dass wird er bis
zum letzten moment offen halten